e aí
olá eu sou regina navarro lins eu tenho
consultório há 46 anos e aconteceu uma
coisa muito curiosa de uns tempos para
cá mais ou menos cinco anos para cá eu
comecei a receber paciente casais trazer
um conflito que eu nunca tinha visto
antes ele chegava no consultório um
punha o outros meios se desesperava e
história é um faz parte do casal queria
uma relação aberta e isso começou a
acontecer com muita frequência não só no
consultório como também recebendo
mensagens né de pessoas que lhe eram
meus livros que me vendo a seleção o que
assistem às palestras muitas mensagens
dizendo que isso está acontecendo aí
você fica pensando mas por que que as
pessoas estão querendo abrir a relação
quem está realmente ocorrendo na vida
dois então vamos ter que fazer uma
viagenzinha história até o século 12 do
século 12 surgiu o amor cortês que eram
porque até o século 12 as pessoas só
podiam amar a deus não existia com
naturalidade amor de uma pessoa por
outra o amor cortês é seria os jovens
nobres é apaixonado pelas damas mulheres
de outros nobres o amor palaciano porque
nessa época do feudalismo é os jovens
estão presas só podiam casar se fosse o
mais velho dos irmãos por um dividir ó
os outros carros que chapado cheio de
energia com as suas armaduras tentei sua
casa sem ter a sua mulher então se
desenvolver o amor cortês um amor
impossível a distância inacessível esse
amor cortês
a origem ao abu romântico que é o amor
que as pessoas suspiram e desejam né que
povoa as mentalidades do acidente a
partir de mais ou menos 1940 o que
aconteceu é que esse amor veio vindo
pela história mas né porque você achava
as pessoas casavam interesses econômicos
interesses políticos o amor era
considerado uma coisa que não podia
entrar no casamento casamento é muito
sério para entrar essa história de amor
que eles acreditavam o amor romântico
veio vindo e passou a ser uma
possibilidade no século 19 mas quando
você ver a temperatura do século 19 que
muita gente ainda casava por decisão da
família pela escolha dos pais muito bem
quando nós chegamos mais ou menos a 1940
o amor romântico começou ganhar muito
eu faço e passou a entrar nos casamentos
é incentivado pelos filmes de hollywood
aqueles filmes melosos é detalhes tem
rock hudson então amor romântico todo
mundo passou a casar por amor queria
casar por amor como antigamente antes é
casar por amor e nem pensado depois
passou a ser criticado quem quisesse
casar sem ser por amor a crítica que eu
faço o amor romântico primer ele é
calcado na idealização quer dizer
baseado naqueles amores impossíveis do
século 12 inclusive a primeira história
de amor é tristão e isolda tempo também
abelardo luiza no século 12 depois no
século 16 temos romeu e julieta são
histórias sempre existe uma interdição
uma proibição a então no século 19
passou a ser uma precisar mais entrou
mesmo no século 20 a crítica
o primeiro a idealização as pessoas elas
idealizam alguém né você idealiza uma
pessoa atribui à ela características que
ela não possui na depois você passa a
vida brigando com a pessoa porque que
elas que aquela se enquadre naquilo que
você imaginou a idealização traz
problemas sérios né porque o casamento
para relação porque na convivência é
impossível você manter denização você
acaba sendo obrigado a perceber aspectos
que você não gosta daquela pessoa não
admira né embora você possa gostar de um
aspecto o outro mas não é realização
você gosta de tudo porque você não se
relaciona com a pessoa real que itália
você se relaciona com a pessoa que você
criou que você inventou por isso que às
vezes a gente vê tanta mágoa tanto
ressentimento
é né quanto maior for a defasagem entre
o que você imaginou que você criou ea
realidade maior vai ser um desencanto né
mas vai ser a mágoa o ressentimento
agora o amor romântico traz outros
características são ideais né são
expectativas por exemplo os dois vão se
transformar em um só que quem ama não
tem desejo sexual por mais ninguém que o
amado é a pessoa mais importante nada
tem sentido na vida se o amado não tiver
crescente que um vai ter suas
características de personalidade
totalmente satisfeitas pelo outro na
verdade nada disso se cumpra né e as
pessoas ficam muito decepcionada e às
vezes é acho que foram enganadas que o
outro mentiu né mãe
bom e o que que tá acontecendo hoje o
amor romântico tá bom vender só tem
olhos um para o outro um só pensa no
outro tudo que o outro faz eu quero ir
junto esse é o amor romântico não existe
individualidade nenhuma ninguém respeita
entrada do outro então é muito comum nos
casamentos você ver um dizendo que o
outro que que tem que dizer para o seu
cunhado o que que tem que ser o seu
chefe você tem que falar de ser assim
fazer a sap bom aí acontece o amor
romântico esse amor que tá entre a gente
mesmo a menos de cem ótimo ele tá dando
sinais de sair de cena
é porque usa seus contemporâneos são
ímpios cá da individualidade cada um
quer saber o seu potencial na vida às
suas possibilidades para desenvolver o
amor romântico propõe o oposto disso ele
propõe a não individualidade quando ele
prega que os dois têm que se transformar
num só então o amor romântico está dando
sinais de sair de cena porque é muito
importante lembrar que o amor é uma
construção social que em cada período da
história essa apresentou de uma forma se
você for olhar história você vai ver que
o amor na grécia era de um jeito na
idade média do outro dos olhos e no
século 19 mudou completamente relação o
século 18 então ele tá dando sinais de
sair de cena por que não está mais
satisfazendo
a anseios contemporâneos a grande viagem
do ser humano é para dentro de si mesmo
agora todos querem realmente se conhecer
saber como pode ver como podem se
desenvolver o amor romântico tão começa
a perder o interesse aos poucos mas é
importante lembrar que a mudança das
mentalidades é lento e gradual eu tô
aprontando o que está começando e as
tendências pode ser que demore 30 anos
ainda três técnicas para o amor
romântico realmente está descendo agora
o importante é que ao sair de cena o
amor romântico está levando com ele a
sua característica básica e a exigência
de exclusividade é claro se um só tem
olhos para o outro se um vai ter suas
satisfações todas suas necessidades
atendidas pelo outro os dois se
transformam só é claro que esse amor pré
a curiosidade tal eu já vi várias
palestras que odeio as pessoas dizerem
coisas do tipo assim amar se relacionou
com outra pessoa então por que não amava
a mulher não amava o marido porque o
amor romântico ele tá entre nós temos
que a gente nasceu né então ele a gente
condicionado por ele condicionamento
cultural é tão forte desde que a gente
nasce que chega à idade adulta você não
sabe o que que você deseja realmente o
que que você aprendeu a desejar então eu
já ouvi várias vezes primeiro que tem
muita gente que acha que amor tem que
ser amor romântico como se faz existe
essa forma de amor o amor romântico é um
tipo de amor que entrou no século 20 na
cultura ocidental time específico do
acidente então amor romântico foi
levando com ele a sua característica
básica que exige
e de exclusividade e ao fazer isso está
abrindo espaço para que as pessoas
escolherão sua forma de amar sua forma
ser relacionado e é por isso que a gente
está vendo surgir em tantas novas formas
de amar olha amor relações livros amor a
três e daí a gente não sabe mais o que
que vem o que acontece o seguinte no
momento em que essa exigência de
exclusividade que sempre foi muito forte
né começa a perder a força começa dá
margem para as pessoas pensarem optarem
por outras formas de amar então você
percebe que as coisas estão começando a
mudar na já diz que eu faço eu vejo que
eu peço para as pessoas mandarem
perguntas é que eu responder nas lajes
no instagram e é é
o site porque a campeã o tema que é
campeão absoluto são dois temas que
estão grandes campeões né o primeiro que
eu não sei na verdade atualmente qual
que é o primeiro qual que é o segundo
mais as perguntas são o que eu digo para
o meu marido que eu quero abrir a
relação o que eu digo para minha
namorada que eu quero abrir relação
abrir a relação significa você não ficar
mais fechado no esquema exclusivamente
monogâmico né então isso se repete as
perguntas são são muitas e também ou
segunda pergunta que se faz muito e que
de alguma forma tá ligado a esse também
é sobre o sexo no casamento eu amo meu
marido é melhor parceiro melhor
companheiro melhor para nós viajamos
saímos com os amigos é ótima vida com
ele só que eu não tenho mais desejo
sexual
em 46 anos de consultório foi o que eu
mais ouvi a mulher chegar sentar no sofá
e de serviço quer dizer os homens
existem um mês que também perdem desejos
e que só mas as mulheres em quantidade
muito maior do que os homens e isso tá
ligado a uma questão que é a falta do
respeito né a individualidade essa coisa
que o amor romântico criou e pregou
partindo de uma premissa que os dois vou
continuar tão interessados pelo outro
como tá na época do namoro no início do
casamento e você vai ficar a vida toda
com aquela pessoa só desejando fazer
sexo com ela só desejando conviver
amorosamente com aquela pessoa que é um
engano né então por que que isso
acontece o não respeito à
individualidade do outro leva isso eu
acredito que uma relação amorosa pode
ser interessante ela pode
o fattoria se as pessoas primeiro se
livrarem destas expectativas do amor
romântico é gostou e se transformar em
um só um só ter olhos para o outro não
vai ficar satisfazer as necessidades
todas do outro e se você se libertar
disso além de é tem total respeito ao
outro hoje é o seu jeito de ser ao seu
jeito de pensar seu comportamento de
liberdade de ir e vir o casal tem que
ter total liberdade né até ter programa
sem ser pagado amigos você não é
obrigada a ter custado os mesmos amigos
para o seu marido gosta o que a sua
mulher gosta e mais do que tudo não
haver controle algum da vida e isso é
muito complicado porque as pessoas
imaginam que se elas não tiverem
controle elas vão perder tem gente que
até aceita ser controlado se isso
e o motivo para controlar o outro então
nós temos sinais dessa mudança de
mentalidade o amor romântico saindo de
serra você pega por exemplo história de
cinderela os contos de fadas né do
príncipe que vem tal na carruagem no
cavalo branco você pega a história da
cinderela que uma história talvez a mais
famosa e você vê que a cinderela ela não
ela não tem projetos próprios ela não
tem nada para suas habilidades seus
talentos a história não uma grande
nítida essa possibilidade ela se
desenvolver ela precisa de um homem para
salvar quais são as histórias hoje a
história estão começando a mudar
histórias infantis que eu começando a
mudar então você tá uma delas história
da valente a valente ela é filha do rei
da rainha mas a mãe quer que ela se
comporte direi
é um príncipe matar a valentina não tá
que disca valente ela quer ficar no arco
e flecha que ela é zinha no arco e
flecha então é organizam no reino um
concurso para o homem que ganhasse
ficaria com a valente só quem ganha
valente tão valente não tá nem um pouco
preocupada em casar com um homem que a
salvo isso é só um sinal nós temos
vários sinais em filmes eu sentaria por
exemplo o filme de woody allen né todos
os dias eu te amo que mostra muito bem é
um é como se fosse uma ironia ao amor
romântico né as pessoas se apaixonam sem
conhecer e enfim é por que idealizam
tudo né tem vários sinais que a gente
pode pegando e você percebe e inclusive
os movimentos dessas novas formas de
amar existem grupos de toalha amor
grupos de relações livres e que as
pessoas dizem que tu não joga
é certo que sempre existiu muito
mistério diz que as pessoas fazem tudo
escondido então eu acredito que daqui a
um tempo talvez predomínio talvez menos
pessoas vão querer se fechar numa
relação a dois e mais gente vai optar
por relações múltiplas para quem fica
surpreso com isso ou acha que a
sociedade não está preparada para é essa
possibilidade eu convido a fazer um
passeio usando 50/60 naquela época
1950/60 se alguém dissesse olha daqui
algumas décadas as pessoas vão poder se
casar ou se separar e não vai ser nenhum
problema porque esse período dos anos
50/60 separação numa tragédia as
mulheres é muitas respeitadas não eram
valorizados existirem escolas que não
deixavam as crianças de pais separados
estudar não mudou
é uma coisa em relação a virgindade
naquela época as moças sempre casar
virgem virgem se alguém diz esta aqui é
o tempo não vai também um achar que a
pessoa não estava sintonizada com nada
bom o que eu quero dizer então é que é
fundamental que a gente reflita sobre os
valores aprendidos sobre as crenças
aprendidas para gente poder se livrar do
moralismo e dos preconceitos eu não
tenho a menor dúvida que todos nós
podemos viver muito melhor do que a
gente vive nessa área do relacionamento
amoroso e sexual mas para refletir sobre
isso para questionar e se livrar do
moralismo dos preconceitos é preciso ter
coragem